dans une déclaration diffusée ce lundi
la télévision d'état met en garde les
protestataires
il y a eu des violations de la loi en
perturbant menaçant les autres par la
force au sein de groupe invoquant les
droits de l'homme et la démocratie comme
excuse sans discipline
la démocratie peut être détruite des
actions doivent être prises conformément
à la loi avec des missions efficace
contre les infractions qui troublent
empêche et détruisent la stabilité de
l'état la sécurité publique et l'état de
droit
on cause les manifestations qui ont
débuté ce samedi
depuis la fronde prend de plus en plus
d'ampleur selon dit selon différentes
estimations
des centaines de milliers de personnes
se sont une nouvelle fois rassemblés à
rangoun
capitale économique du pays des
rassemblements notamment à l'initiative
de la jeunesse pour dénoncer la prise du
pouvoir par les généraux on voit bien
que beaucoup de jeunes ne peuvent pas
accepter la junte militaire on peut même
trouver des adolescents ici pour nous on
se joint à la manifestation ensemble
avec mes enfants mes nièces et neveux
je soutiens les jeunes qui prennent
activement part à la manifestation
notre pays sera mieux seulement s'il se
bat contre la junte militaire
ils doivent tous avoir ce genre de
courage pour notre futur
les mobilisations se multiplient à
travers le pays et le nouveau pouvoir
prend les premières mesures la loi
martiale a été décrétée dans plusieurs
quartiers de mandat les deuxièmes plus
grandes villes du pays les
manifestations et les rassemblements de
plus de cinq personnes sont interdits et
en couvre feu est instauré de 20 heures
à 4 heures du matin